larissa's in billings i was there
yesterday
larissa i was up there fly fishing it's
beautiful country i've never been there
before
how are you it is good it is beautiful
up here
a little hospital right now yeah so
i have been having some anxiety about
paying my credit card bills off i have
to take that money out of savings and
pay it off and it's really hard
because it's not there anymore so i went
ahead and called
uh chase one of my credit card companies
and i wanted to do a little negotiating
with them to
settle are you behind i know i'm not
behind
well they don't settle with people that
aren't behind honey
oh i didn't know that i was asking about
well i was calling to ask if they if i
had to what would be the better option
no they don't they don't like write down
debt unless they think they're not gonna
get their money
if you hadn't paid them and if you
hadn't paid i'm not suggesting this
don't do it but if you hadn't paid them
in six months
right then they get they get in the mood
to settle because they think you're a
deadbeat
okay larissa how long were you on the
phone with them before you found out
that they're not budging
oh my goodness an hour they gave me the
run around they hung up on me twice it
was ridiculous
it is ridiculous so and you want to keep
them around huh i ride check pay those
people off and get them out of my life
say chase this
yes i know i need to do that now that i
i
realize that i was thinking that they
would settle with me at one point one of
them told me they would do 90 cents on
the dollar
wow i'm surprised i wanted to try to get
yeah i wanted to try to get that in
writing
and then the supervisor came on and said
no we're not going to do that anymore
yeah yeah and this person doesn't work
anymore
marge is no longer with us larissa how
much do you owe
on this credit card uh
and how much do you have in savings i
can pay it off
recently how much do you have in savings
about 12 000. about 12 000.
how many other credit cards do you owe
on
one other and it's only about two
thousand okay
you got 12 000 in savings so you could
pay both of these off by the time you
hang up with dave and i
i sure could i sure could you ain't you
got any scissors
no i'm going to by by the end of this
week that's my goal
why are you waiting three more days end
of the day
get your scissors out time get them out
right now let's hear some plastic
surgery right here
i wanna hear you talking about them get
them out go go over to the drawer and
get some scissors right now
do you make don't make us come out there
to billings
larissa i actually don't have the credit
cards anymore
where are they been paying on them to
get them down where are they they've
been cut up
they've been cut up a long time ago oh
we've
made a good first step on them so hey
all joking and kidding around the side
okay
when you hang up the phone call them and
pay them both off okay
all right love you will do we appreciate
you calling